[Musique]
c'est dans la peine et la douleur que
nous sommes rassemblés ce midi cela fait
effectivement un an jour pour jour que
l'Ukraine subit l'agression de l'armée
russe un an que le quotidien de
l'Ukraine est rythmé par la guerre je ne
peux vous cacher mon inquiétude devant
l'évolution de ce conflit inquiet pour
ce grand pays voisin a mis et souverain
l'Ukraine
inquiet pour notre civilisation l'Europe
inquiet du retour de la guerre sur le
sol européen
qui menace l'équilibre du monde
il faut rester optimiste et continuer
d'être solidaire avec le peuple
ukrainien comme les le département de la
Vienne depuis le début comme nous le
sommes tous ensemble dans la Vienne avec
les 700 Ukrainiens en exil qui ont été
accueillis ici n'oublions jamais que le
peuple
ukrainien se bat pour sa liberté
mais aussi pour la nôtre alors que vive
la liberté et que triomphe la paix
vive la Vienne vive l'Ukraine vive la
liberté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]